ce sont de véritables ouvrière dans un
rayon pouvant aller jusqu'à 3 km une
abeille est capable de butiner 500
fleurs par jour genre de chasse va les
responsables des ruchers de la ferme de
gally après l'hiver ils vérifient l'état
des ruches c'est la découverte première
visite de printemps on regarde ce qui
s'est passé pendant l'hiver
on va regarder les réserves qui reste
hélas pas grand chose dans cette ruche
mais on constate quand même il ya
beaucoup de pollen et ça c'est du jeune
paul allen qui a été récolté depuis le
mois de février
cette ruche est en bonne santé mais ce
n'est pas le cas partout
chaque année 30 % des colonies
d'abeilles disparaissent en cause les
pesticides les maladies mais aussi le
manque de nourriture depuis septembre
2016 les fermes de gally mène une étude
avec le docteur kim nguyen spécialiste
des abeilles
une colonne abc cinquante mille abeilles
elles vont collecter plus de 4 milliards
d'échantillons dans leur environnement
sur 700 hectares avons ramené tous à
l'intérieur de la ruche et nous allons
analyser l'eau collectée ou sly analyses
en laboratoire en fonction des résultats
qu'on a obtenus on peut vous dire là il
ya des pesticides quelles sont les
mesures qu'on peut prendre avec les
agriculteurs pour limiter l'usagé des
pesticides
on a retrouvé les carences alimentaires
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais on fait
des plantations avec des citoyens comme
ici on va le faire essayer notamment des
plantations pour nourrir les abeilles en
période creuse les fermes de gally
sensibilise le public à privilégier les
plantes qui fleurissent à différents
moments céanothes brouyère myosotis
elles vont aller dans le jardin de
chacun sur le balcon pour pouvoir
butiner ces plantes mellifères qui
doivent fleurir de but le début de la
saison mais aussi jusqu'à la fin de
l'automne nourrir les abeilles pour
qu'elle puisse nourrir un cycle vertueux
le résultat de l'étude sera connu fin
c'est la première de ce type en ile de
france